hey guys today it is the 7th of March my
name is Jess and your change into games
but news here's the good Blizzard has
revealed details about the beta and
release date for their upcoming shooter
overwatch the open beta will run from a
529 on xbox one ps4 and PC although if
you are to pre order before April 29
you'll be able to play starting may
three and also invite a friend along the
beta will let you play any of / watches
21 characters and access every map that
will be available in the full game at
launch lizard have said we want players
to get a feel for the complete overwatch
experience PlayStation 4 owners won't
need PS Plus to access the beta but will
when the full game releases however xbox
one owners will need a live gold
membership to play the beta and the full
game lizard confirmed that beta
progression will not carry forward to
the full game which will land on May 24
and is priced at 60 bucks its division
day for those of you who missed the memo
the videos and the livestream so here's
the latest on the just-released shooter
Ubisoft confirmed that the underground
and survival expansion packs will arrive
on xbox one 30 days before other
platforms while the divisions third
expansion last stand won't be exclusive
to any one platform for any amount of
time according to polygon all three
expansions are included with the
divisions $40 season pass in addition to
coming with the games gold and
collector's editions Ubisoft also
confirmed that the first two free
updates will launch simultaneously
across platforms aside from what is
releasing where and when I community
data mining effort revealed a bunch of
division info including that the game
will feature a destiny asked endgame
leveling system once please hit the soft
level cap of 30 they will be able to
acquire a high level endgame equipment
to progress further while in destiny
this is referred to as light
level in the division it will be called
gear score a line from the leak as
reported by Eurogamer suggests with
extra challenges will be unlocked by
increasing your gear score this latest
information leak which has come by a
reddit user Christian reason also
confirms an item trading system and
daily and weekly missions which ask you
to complete combat dark soon and casting
objective the data mine suggests the
division will have at least 26 missions
at launch with a main game length of
approximately 10 to 11 hours finally
Microsoft has ceased development on
fable legends and is in discussions to
close lionhead studios the news was
revealed by Microsoft Studios Europe GM
hanno Lemke on the official Xbox
newswire he explained after much
consideration we've decided to cease
development on fable legends and during
discussions with employees about the
proposed closure of lionhead studios in
the UK lion head was founded by peter
molyneux in 1996 and is known primarily
for the fable series it was acquired by
microsoft in 2006 and Molyneux left the
company in 2012 Lemke added the
denmark-based press PLAY Studios
responsible for kalimba and max the
curse of brotherhood has in clothes and
work on multiplayer game project
Knoxville has been suspended Lemke
explained we are committed to working
closely with those affected by today's
news to find the new opportunities at
xbox or partnering with the broader
development community to help place them
in jobs elsewhere in the games industry
should they desire at gamespot we wish
all the best to those affected let me
know down in that comment section if
you're planning on picking up the
division and we shot ads gamespot we've
got stories on sniper elite 4 and
reverse sleep for doom that's everything
I happy today enjoy playing the division
or whatever else you may be doing with
your day and I will see you again sir